hi my name is anika no knee rose and i
play
jessica jangle hi i'm felicia richard
and i play the grandmother
hi i'm madeline mills and i play journey
hello i am keegan michael key
and i am here promoting the movie jingle
jangle a christmas journey
and we're about to take a fun buzzfeed
quiz
to find out which jingle jangle or
christmas journey character we are
[Music]
what's your favorite part about
christmas presents
family time holiday food christmas
movies
decorating or christmas scents i'm gonna
have to go with holiday food
family time i like the time that i spend
with the people around me so i'm i'm
gonna click
family time i'm gonna choose decorating
i'm gonna choose family time pick a
christmas song
to sing for karaoke all i want for
christmas is you
santa baby let it snow santa claus is
coming to town
i saw mommy kissing santa claus and
this christmas i like to go to the old
classics
and so i'm gonna pick let it snow that's
the one that really gets me in the
spirit here
i'm gonna go with the classic here all i
want for christmas is you
i think i'm gonna choose our down and
dirty r b in the spirit of jingle jangle
and hit with this christmas
i'm doing that one this christmas pick a
christmas snack
gingerbread house hot chocolate candy
canes
christmas cookies popcorn garland
and fruitcake i don't even really know
what popcorn garland is it seems like
that
you would only be eating the popcorn
part but as i look at this picture
there's like cranberries
nobody i know in the history of the
world has ever eaten
just like a regular cranberry that's its
own quiz do you know anybody who's ever
eaten an
actual regular cranberry i'm choosing
the gingerbread
house i'm going to go with hot chocolate
because i'm a chocolate
enthusiast i'm a christmas cookies
person and i think it's safe to say just
i want to make sure everybody knows
gingerbread house is an extremely close
second christmas cookies
my nickname on broadway was the cookie
monster
i'm a cookie how would your friends
describe
you during the holidays jolly anxious
generous grumpy exhausted
or creative i am a notoriously jolly
during the holidays so i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with jolly creative
generous i like to give a gift i
am gonna go with charlie cause i like to
entertain
choose a sidekick to go on a christmas
adventure with
a cat in a like a full-on santa suit
a dog which is like a dachshund puppy
unbelievable
the cuteness factor here's like a 286.
then there's like a straight
up salamander like a straight up
salamander
it's a lizard of some sort he's got his
little christmas hat on which doesn't
make computer
it doesn't work then you've got guinea
pigs and then
i believe this is either a llama or an
alpaca and then
a like flop-eared rabbit i'm gonna
choose a llama
because why not i'm gonna choose a
rabbit well i'd love to
you know do some fun christmas caroling
with a llama
i'm going to choose a cat because i
actually have a very
loving cat who doesn't like to travel
but is a really really good traveler i'm
gonna have to go
with this little dachshund he's he's
just adorable he's killing me with the
straight adorbs over here
and finally pick a movie to end the
night with
there's home alone with christmas story
elf it's a wonderful life the nightmare
before christmas
and how the grinch stole christmas
i'm gonna go with the grinch probably
how the grinch stole christmas yeah i
can't choose anything else
welcome christmas grinch stole
it no this is an easy one for me it's a
christmas story every year
whenever i have an opportunity that's my
jam christmas story is my jam
[Music]
oh
i knew it i called it i'm buddy and i am
jeronicus jangle
wow i got
grandma journey what okay yeah all right
who doesn't want to be felicia
who doesn't want to just walk around
earth and just be the definition of
grace
thank you very much i've learned some
things about myself today i'm kiki
michael key from jingle jangle a
christmas journey
have a happy holiday season
[Music]
you